[Aplausos]
[Música]
en las últimas décadas ha sido algo muy
normal considerar al inquilino de la
casa blanca al presidente de los eeuu
como la persona más poderosa del planeta
[Música]
sin embargo amigos las cosas pueden
estar cambiando o incluso pueden haber
cambiado ya conocéis al presidente chino
sí desde luego que sí aquí en visual
político hemos hablado ya a alguna que
otra vez de él pues bien fijaos el
mismísimo donald trump en declaraciones
recogidas por el 'washington post' ha
calificado a este presidente chino xi
jinping como el líder más poderoso que
china ha tenido en el último siglo lo
que es tanto como decir que si jinping
es el líder chino más poderoso de todos
los tiempos
[Música]
tanto que cada vez más analistas se
preguntan si no estaremos ya ante el
líder político más poderoso del mundo si
es verdad tanto la economía de china
como su ejército siguen estando en un
segundo nivel si lo comparamos con eeuu
pero mientras que trump parece perder
minuto a minuto influencia en el mundo y
también dentro de casa xi jinping sigue
el camino opuesto un momento que eeuu
contra anv está perdiendo influencia
pero si últimamente donald quiere ser el
amigo de todos habéis visto este tweet
tan tierno porque yo no insultaría
llamándome viejo cuando yo nunca le
llamaría bajo y gordo o bueno trato
tanto de ser su amigo y quizás algún día
eso ocurra si definitivamente no me
extraña que eeuu esté perdiendo
influencia en el mundo en pocos meses
trump ha pasado de la guerra nuclear a
la pelea de patio de colegio
en fin en serio el caso es que aunque
sigue
no es el presidente de la primera
potencia del mundo controla férreamente
la dirección de china uno de los motores
económicos más importantes del planeta
y desde luego amigos trump ha sido para
pekín como decirlo algo así como un gran
premio de la lotería atentos
el proteccionismo el nacionalismo y los
errores de donald trump le han permitido
a xi jinping el presidente de chiná la
mayor dictadura del mundo presentar su
candidatura a una especie de liderazgo
político mundial en enero de 2017 en el
foro de davos
xi jinping prometió que china se
convertiría ni más ni menos que en el
campeón de la globalización el libre
comercio e incluso la lucha contra el
cambio climático
de esta forma pekín aspira a quedarse
con el terreno que está perdiendo
washington en la política internacional
lo que se le olvidó fue hablar de
libertad y tal pero sí
jinping
se derivaba de shandong
en tanto cuando lo que pasó en el último
congreso del partido comunista chino
cuánto poder tiene xi jinping qué es lo
que quiere bien vamos a verlo pero antes
echemos un vistazo a china
[Música]
la nueva china pensáis que china sigue
siendo ese país donde las personas
malviven deslomándose a trabajar por
salarios miserables pues lo siento pero
estáis algo equivocados en 2018 se
cumple el 40 aniversario de la política
de reforma y apertura de china y en este
tiempo el país ha cambiado muchísimo
china ya no es un país de ingresos bajos
sino uno de ingresos medios
de hecho teniendo en cuenta la
diferencia de precios esto es lo que se
denomina paridad de poder adquisitivo su
pib per cápita viene a ser de unos
16.000 dólares algo superior al de
colombia o brasil por ejemplo
además su economía ha cambiado y hoy los
servicios son ya la actividad más
importante
[Música]
hablamos por ejemplo del comercio
electrónico un sector en el que está por
delante de europa e incluso de eeuu
chinas representa ni más ni menos que el
40 por ciento de todas las transacciones
en el mundo lo mismo podemos decir de
los pagos móviles tan popularizados en
este país que su mercado alcanzó en 2016
los 5,5 billones de dólares 50 veces más
que en eeuu
[Música]
no está mal verdad el crecimiento ha
sido de tal magnitud que tan solo en los
últimos seis años el consumo privado de
los chinos ha crecido en 25 billones de
dólares una cifra equivalente atentos a
todo el pib de la india por todo esto
amigos no es extraño que cuando
visitamos alguna de las grandes ciudades
chinas nos encontremos con un país
repleto de rascacielos multimillonarios
y trenes de alta velocidad pero esperad
un momento si es verdad en china sigue
habiendo pobreza y en general hay una
gran diferencia entre las ciudades y las
zonas rurales que siguen siendo pobres
muy pobres
[Música]
43 millones de personas casi la
población de toda españa' siguen
viviendo en una situación de extrema
pobreza con menos de un dólar al día y
no sólo eso cerca del 40% de los chinos
aunque mucho mejor que hace décadas
siguen viviendo en un nivel económico
bastante bajo
pero como os decía antes las cosas están
cambiando muy rápido y ya no podemos
pensar en chinas de la misma forma que
lo hacíamos hace 2010 o incluso 5 años
[Música]
por cierto precisamente en relación a la
pobreza algo bastante curioso sabéis
cómo enfoca el gobierno chino la lucha
contra la pobreza pues una de sus
principales estrategias pasa por
conseguir que en las comunidades más
pobres se creen nuevas empresas y
cooperativas tan solo a este fin el
gobierno lleva concedidos ojo casi 400
mil millones de dólares en pequeños
préstamos que permiten que muchas
empresas se puedan poner en marcha y ojo
no se trata sólo de un enfoque de dinero
también en cierto modo es cultural los
noticiarios nocturnos están llenos de
historias sobre las comunidades
renovadas y los habitantes de estos
sitios que se han convertido en
empresarios y que llenan de halagos a sí
y al gobierno
javier hernández corresponsal en china
del 'new york times'
[Música]
lo sé soy impini prácticamente todos los
jerarcas del país hablan mucho de
socialismo al estilo chino en realidad
no es más que una fórmula para hablar de
una especie de modelo capitalista
encerrado en una dictadura porque amigos
china no es una dictadura ideológica ni
socialista ni comunista es simplemente
una dictadura pero bien dicho esto
hablemos de xi jinping la persona que
dirige con un poder prácticamente total
esta nueva china
xi jinping el líder
nacido en 1953 sin fin amigos es un tipo
muy curioso por un lado es probablemente
el líder chino que más contacto ha
tenido con occidente su hija sin ir más
lejos estudió en harvard una hermana
suya vive en canadá y él mismo conoce
bien lo ha visitado muchas veces eeuu
de hecho en 2012 cuando visitó eeuu en
calidad de vicepresidente de china hizo
una parada un tanto peculiar fue a
visitar a agua agua porque agua le
preguntó el mismísimo obama pues el caso
es que en 1985 cuando se impidera un
joven secretario del partido en un
condado de china hizo un viaje a iowa
con el fin de investigar temas
relacionados con la agricultura así que
en 2012 fue a ver a la familia con la
que se quedó por aquel entonces y les
llevó regalos vaya historia verdad
además el lado yanqui del presidente si
no queda ahí también es bien conocido
que le encantan las películas bélicas de
hollywood si películas como salvar al
soldado ryan
cual como lo escucháis sin embargo al
mismo tiempo desde que se convirtió en
la máxima autoridad de china hace cinco
años su gobierno se ha caracterizado por
ser el más censor y represor en mucho
tiempo no tenemos más que fijarnos en la
última ley de ciberseguridad que busca
controlar aún más internet en china
restringiendo el anonimato hasta tal
punto que por ejemplo obliga a que las
redes sociales todas las cuentas estén
respaldadas por un ciudadano real
perfectamente identificado
además todo ello ha estado acompañado
por una política de culto al líder
también inédita en mucho tiempo si
podemos decir que los servicios de
propaganda han trabajado a destajo pero
bueno nada que pueda sorprendernos
verdad
[Música]
y en el caso es que en estos cinco años
sin pena ha hecho muchos cambios en
china empezando por la reforma del
ejército o por una política exterior
particularmente activa lo hemos visto
aquí en visual político sin fin ha
puesto los recursos nacionales al
servicio de la política exterior ahí
está por ejemplo el macro proyecto de la
nueva ruta de la seda que planea
invertir cientos de miles de millones de
dólares en un montón de países pero con
todo su mayor apuesta ha sido sin duda
la lucha contra la corrupción en estos
años el régimen chino ha sancionado a
más de un millón y medio de miembros del
partido comunista y procesado a casi
300.000 incluyendo a 43 miembros del
comité central también en el marco de
esta lucha contra la corrupción 13.000
oficiales del ejército han sido
despedidos y más de 50 generales
encarcelados
claro que no todo el mundo ve esta
batalla como algo tan limpio y honesto
es una selectiva campaña anticorrupción
su objetivo es una protección selectiva
de la corrupción cuando purgas a algunos
cargos corruptos estás protegiendo al
resto proteges el sistema corrupto y
proteger a corruptos que te apoyan
mautone activista chino xi jinping ha
depurado sobre todo a sus rivales
políticos casualidad coincidencia bueno
desde luego lo que está claro es que en
estos cinco años y jin pyng ha ganado
mucho poder esto amigos es algo que se
ha visto perfectamente en el último
congreso del partido comunista de china
el evento político más importante de
este país y que se celebra cada cinco
años atentos
[Música]
el décimo noveno congreso
este décimo noveno congreso del partido
comunista chino celebrado entre los días
18 y 24 de octubre del 2017 fue bastante
peculiar empezando porque tal vez ha
sido el congreso más austero que el
partido comunista chino ha celebrado en
muchos muchísimos años y en esta ocasión
se eliminaron algunas comodidades
queréis algún ejemplo pues entre otras
cosas ojo que esto va en serio no es
broma se suprimió la barra libre de
langostinos y también los servicios de
peluquería tratamiento facial y
sastrería que se ofrecían gratis a los
participantes y que eran ya casi como
una tradición pero por encima de todo
este ha sido el congreso en el que
siguen pink ha sido elevado a los
altares algo que como os podéis imaginar
en china quiere decir ser puesto al
nivel casi de mao tse tung
hace cinco años que predije que si sería
el líder más poderoso de china desde el
shopping me equivoqué
se ha convertido en el líder más
poderoso desde mao tse tung kevin rat ex
primer ministro de australia veréis en
este congreso se ha decidido que el
llamado pensamiento de xi jinping se ha
incluido en la constitución del partido
comunista esto puede parecernos un poco
raro pero lo que viene a significar es
que siguen pin ya no es un líder más es
el líder con mayúsculas
el líder cuya palabra forma la propia
ideología del partido la inclusión de su
pensamiento significa que si es
intocable si lo cuestionas estás
cuestionando al partido y no quieres
tener al partido en contra y es que
hasta ahora solo mao tse tung había
recibido semejante honor en vida pero
ahí no acaba todo
actualmente el mandato de un presidente
está limitado a diez años de tal forma
que este que comienza sería el último
mandato de celine pin pero un momento
porque en esta ocasión no se ha
contemplado ningún sucesor así que
apunta a que si jinping aspirar a por lo
menos a tener un tercer mandato
[Música]
las universidades chinas luchan por
abrir centros para estudiar el
pensamiento del presidente xi jinping
pero bueno más allá del líder chino este
congreso ha servido para marcar las tres
grandes prioridades del gobierno chino
en los próximos años primero la economía
combatir la pobreza y abrirse más al
mundo segundo poner en marcha una
política exterior aún más fuerte y
tercero empezar a preocuparse del medio
ambiente y bueno aunque he dicho tres
prioridades hay una cuarta que ha
quedado muy clara consolidar el poder
del partido comunista
porque amigos hay dos cosas que han
quedado muy claras por un lado que
tendremos xi jinping y partido comunista
para rato por otro que china reclama su
papel como superpotencia acostumbrémonos
a tener en cuenta
a pekín pero en fin ahora turno para ti
quién consideras que va a dejar primero
el poder
xi jinping o vladimir putin déjanos tu
respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta si te ha gustado el
vídeo dale a like y no olvides
suscribirte a visual política un saludo
y hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]